en medio de una ola de calor sin
precedentes y un aumento del descontento
social en Argentina el enre el ente
regulador de la electricidad denunció
penalmente a la empresa distribuidora de
energía edesur por pedido del gobierno
nacional luego de que decenas de miles
de usuarios se quedaran sin servicio en
el área metropolitana de Buenos Aires
algunos por más de una semana el
gobierno Está avanzando el Enrique fue
mandatado con la indicación de la
secretaria de energía del ministro de
economía para presentar hoy mismo con
las próximas horas una denuncia penal
contra el gerente general de la empresa
edesur y todos los miembros de su
directorio por malversación de fondos
fraude en perjuicio de la Administración
pública y abandono de personas el
gobierno también advirtió que evaluará
un informe del Henry y en los próximos
90 días estudiará la posibilidad de
revocar la concesión a la compañía
eléctrica por su parte los ciudadanos
continúan con sus reclamos mientras
crece la desesperación
es un servicio esencial a la luz no es
un lujo es un servicio esencial tenemos
la comida podrida dentro de las
heladeras del Freezer reclamas Sí pero
mientras tanto tenés que salir a comprar
agua tenés que salir a comprarle la
comida para el ratito ni siquiera para
el día para el ratito es hace un calor
desesperante además de la ciudad de
Buenos Aires también ha presentado una
denuncia al igual que la localidad de
Esteban Echeverría que registró
problemas de operatividad en el hospital
municipal mientras que en otras ciudades
del sur de la provincia miles de
personas tampoco tienen agua potable
porque el funcionamiento de la empresa
encargada no tiene suministro eléctrico